Sandy Springs has no long-term
liabilities as no long-term liabilities
local governments across the country are
failing their citizens mired in debt and
unfunded pension obligations more and
more cities are cutting services and
raising taxes according to the National
League of Cities American municipalities
will likely face a shortfall between
sixty and eighty billion dollars between
2010 and 2012 but in Sandy Springs a
city of 100,000 people on the north side
of Atlanta something extraordinary is
happening in comparison to all these
other cities and counties that are
having to furlough and having these
terrible pension problems our situation
is excellent Ava galambos is a former
economist and the mayor of Sandy Springs
Georgia a few years ago galambos and the
committee for Sandy Springs set out to
create a completely new kind of city a
fiscally accountable city whose goal it
is to provide quality services at a
reasonable price long-time sandy springs
resident oliver porter was also a member
of the committee for sandy springs the
responsibility for actually implementing
the city fell on my shoulders Porter is
a retired corporate executive and artist
and the author of two books on how to
create a 21st century city this is the
story of Sandy Springs Georgia the city
that out sourced everything
[Music]
five years ago
the Sandy Springs community was an
unincorporated part of Fulton County
Georgia for many many years the Fulton
County ruled us from downtown Atlanta
we were taxed heavily and big in being a
more affluent community more of the
taxes were gathered here and then very
little of the money was being spent here
so the people in Sandy Springs got
pretty tired of this we wanted local
control we wanted to have a voice in our
own government and we wanted to keep our
local money at home in Georgia the state
legislature must authorize a referendum
before a new city can incorporate in the
summer of 2005 Sandy Springs
decades-long fight for independence
finally paid off
the legislature was totally controlled
by the Democrats and as soon as the
majority became Republican we passed the
bill to authorize the referendum and
Sandy Springs and it passed with 92% of
the vote came up with the concept of
using the private industry out of
necessity because as volunteer group we
had no authority no funds no staff and
would not have any of those until the
moment the city was formed and at that
moment we had to be a functional City
Sandy Springs incorporated on December
1st 2005 the new city government
contracted with the company ch2m Hill to
pave the streets pick up the trash
maintain the parks and do virtually
everything else we expect our municipal
governments to do the contract is not a
single company but it is a managing
partner with a with a large number of
subcontractors specializing in the areas
so they provide the internal functions
of the admin the finance etc and then
they go out and they get subcontractors
to do the other functions and companies
are good at managing that better it
turns out then governments are why did
Sandy Springs choose a public-private
partnership for starters ch2m Hill did
its job for 25 million dollars the first
year in a traditionally run city
those same city services would have cost
50 million dollars it's a big
improvement over I know what Fulton
County was before a huge improvement we
have far exceeded any expectation that I
had by operating more efficiently Sandy
Springs has been able to make the kinds
of capital investments that Fulton
County had failed to make for decades we
never saw any paving of roads our roads
were deteriorating and we have paved and
paved something like 90 miles of streets
we built several new parks some of them
are already won awards this is a rather
new I think it's been here for about a
year so this is a fantastic development
for family we have probably the most
state-of-the-art traffic management
system now in certainly Georgia maybe in
the country in terms of fuel and time
investing in a cutting-edge traffic
control system has saved Sandy Springs
motorists around 12 million dollars over
the past two years virtually the only
thing sandy springs doesn't outsource
our police and fire services but unlike
so many other cities Sandy Springs
hasn't fallen into the pension trap when
we began the city we made a clear
decision that we wouldn't have defined
contribution in for one case and we were
not going into defined benefits so we
did that to begin with we also put in
help plans where you can put the money
into a savings account with no pension
storm on the horizon sandy springs is
able to focus on giving the people what
they want high quality public safety
services 9-1-1 system that has been
employed is certainly state-of-the-art
far superior to the county here
everything is we do is a lot different
and many of the ideas and things that we
do today or come from our people and we
have paramedics that are just
cutting-edge we have tools that are
cutting-edge I've actually had to use
them right after Sandy Springs became
Sandy Springs and they were when they're
in our house
within minutes and it was very
comforting so far in the last four years
we have 25 confirmed saves of people who
basically had died and we brought them
back and despite all its investments
Sandy Springs has managed to remain
fiscally sound not only has a city been
able to operate with no increase in
taxes whatsoever on property taxes but
it has built a reserve and increase the
capital programs throughout while the
unincorporated force remaining
unincorporated portion of the county has
actually increased its taxes it is
possible if you're efficient with that
same millage rate to get something done
and I think that's the best proof that
this model works to me the most single
most important public opinion survey was
the first election held after the city
was started four years after was started
and every incumbent that ran risk the
least vote wantem received was 84%
that's an amazing number since 2005 for
other Georgia cities have incorporated
and Oliver Porter helped all of them
implement the Sandy Springs model can
existing cities realize the same kind of
efficiencies by outsourcing city
services the difficult news if you were
trying to convert an existing city is
the placenta the political situation you
have existing employees often unionized
who just by nature going to be opposed
to this they're going to be concerned I
can see why the public employees are
reticent and nobody likes change anyway
nobody likes change but if your city is
fixing to go bankrupt they may have to
be some change I think everyone is aware
of the financial difficulties of so many
municipalities across the country and I
think it's time that people get very
serious about looking for an alternative
and I know of no better alternative to
look to than the public-private
partnership model
[Music]
you